[Music]
in taken news of bacon like the movie
maybe like the movie oh and I know
submitted by Yasmin Bessie you that is
me I submitted this and I just changed
my name to a why yes a model was held at
ransom after she was kidnapped me sold
as a sex slave damn and she's a mono
that's just like the movie literally I
saw it there was no dad to come and get
her that everyone can have Liam Neeson s
attack oh man
that's like my night man if someone uses
me online and it was popular model there
I think you'll be safe I think you could
sleep at night
what if like I get kidnapped and I'm
like I wake up in Ukraine or something
and then they use me as a cowboy you can
walk naked down the streets at 2:00 a.m.
and you're safe you never know there's a
lot of perverts Oh crazy you're [ __ ]
safe but you know I can't like I'm kind
of famous online and people just if they
want a dictator porn to create a Josie
Tiffany
he's [ __ ] safe I scared ya so this
model is from the UK her name is Chloe
ailing she's 20 years old Wow she's 20
that's crazy it's so young yeah she's
super gay back in April she was hired to
do a photo shoot in Paris and so she was
paid 900 pounds up front to do this
shoot you set her up in a really nice
hotel around like a Shawntel is a it was
really nice right but then the shoot was
cancelled due to terroristic attack that
happened and so she went home fine
everything was fine
so then again she was booked with the
same photographer so his fake name is
Andre leis oh so he was claiming to be
an Italian photographer but it turns out
to be this Polish man who lives in the
UK named Lucas herba 30 years old damn
polish hot dogs
again he paid her 900 pounds upfront to
do a photo shoot but this time in Milan
cuz he said that he had to change his
Studios and now he's not in Paris
anymore not even Milan so they already
had a prior working relationship sort of
because that shoot got cancelled oh okay
no mine so they didn't work together
yeah not really but they were supposed
to work together so then that's why like
I guess she trusted him and but it
became a trusting relationship like she
she goes out there and then that's when
she says that she got attacked by two
men she was drugged with ketamine
they transported her two hours to a
remote farmhouse they handcuffed her to
a wooden chest of drawers in the bedroom
and she said this quote a person wearing
black gloves came up from behind and put
one hand on my neck and the other around
my mouth while a second person wearing a
black mask injected me in my right arm I
think I lost consciousness when I woke
up I was wearing a pink bodysuit and the
socks I'm in now I realized I was in the
butiful car with my wrists and ankles
tied and my mouth tape I was inside a
bag with only a small hole that allowed
me to breach and so like she says she
was screaming so much and the time that
she was in the trunk that the kidnappers
had to stop three times to shut her up
and then like they held her for six days
until they've discovered that she was in
long because they saw that she's saying
that the boss looked at her Instagram
account and saw that she has a
two-year-old son and that apparently in
that in this specific group that they
have a rule against kidnapping moms and
selling what they have morals now that's
so weird
guys guys guys we can't do this why
she's got a kid I don't understand it's
just let her go they go through all that
work but then they just go mad with us
we can't do this I feel like the whole
situation who just accepts money like
900 pounds for a photographer who
probably doesn't have much of a
following or portfolio really anything
to prove for himself what if he has a
fake Instagram account with a bunch of
hop models and I guess so
a lot of people would do that yeah
especially they front you the money yeah
maybe I'm just paired and you can go
with someone that you trust
I you take your boyfriend or something I
would do it without anybody to a free
trip to since she's a model like does
she have a manager or anyone done yeah
so what happened was they sent Iran
she's only 20 does she looks older and
she's got a two-year-old kid
her lawyer his name is Phil green who
runs the super model agency I she works
which he received an email after he
didn't hear from Chloe for a couple days
an email said quote we've got Chloe
ailing we are black death group it is of
supreme interest that you raise money
you should contact an English three
names or she will be sold at auction on
Sunday and handed to the Russian mafia
we require you to come up with an offer
by Sunday or she will be placed for
auction two Russians are scary too it'll
[ __ ] around in Russia no they eat like
sturgeon eggs and stuff hey what
sturgeon eggs that's a caviar so
allegedly the captors listed her on the
dark web for two hundred and thirty
thousand British pounds which is about
three hundred thousand US dollars as a
sex slave and then they're assuming that
would be for Middle Eastern fighters
that's the story it turned out that
there was evidence or like footage of
her shopping with her captor a couple of
days before they've dropped her off at
the Embassy because that's once they
found out that she was a mom they
dropped her off at the British Embassy
in Italy but then gathers like proof
that she was shoe shopping with this
dude so they're cool so if they're in
cahoots kind of it's fishy I feel like
they're making this like big so they can
get her name out and now we can make her
popular so that's the one fishy thing
right but then she says that you know
what like I there's no reasonable
explanation for it other than the fact
that I was just trying to do whatever
they wanted me to do to not anger them
or anything - she was scared for her
safety if you girls were in public right
with the captor and they don't have
anyone else like in ransom why don't you
just [ __ ] signal to life yeah yeah or
just run insane
I feel like I'd be too afraid to do that
yeah some groomers good
I'd be like what if they have a gun and
then you know they already kidnap me
like they might pull out that gun and
just [ __ ] shoot both me and this I'd
rather die than be sold for sex so I'm
doing it yeah but if you're in public
obviously they're not gonna do stuff
unless they've already proven that they
will I go say they beat the [ __ ] out of
you like to the brink of death yeah and
then then when you're like when you're
out in public you I think when you have
that trauma you probably would behave
you become like a reek from Game of
Thrones you're so traumatized it's like
your parents beat the show when your
parents beat the crap out of you right
like when you're in public now all your
mom or dad has to do is like and you're
like oh [ __ ] I know what that means yeah
exactly
I just get sucked in and imagine cuz
they know that they're most likely gonna
have to go back there so they're like
what are they gonna do to me when I get
back even just for making a motion that
I was gonna try and escape I cause a
scene thing is the fact that she's just
immediately booking shoots now yeah you
would need sometime even like when that
whole Kim Kardashian scandal happened
she like what am i a for a while
look when she got jacked and pet France
or something yeah when they like tied
her up and stuff I don't like I feel
like if that was I mean anybody would
need time yeah the reason to me is just
too [ __ ] stupid like Oh guys guys
she's a mom it is weird because they're
willing to take a woman and sell them
into sexual slavery why the [ __ ] would
they care if she has a kid not only that
but they already invested money in
flying her to do all this work flying
her beardy no your face they're gonna
get caught they know the name of the
group and everything so what like yeah
that doesn't make sense that that makes
us it doesn't make sure that group it is
a real group so they have been known to
sell girls into sex slavery and stuff
but everything else about it is just
seems kind of but I'll show you more
photos this issue looks like is here
with your baby so they're saying that
this is like the photo that saved your
life the baby say the baby look so
worried baby don't go outside
don't go outside on the future I learned
an episode of Sister Sister on Disney
Channel
when tan Tamara try and go to a photo
shoot and the guy is a pervert to never
go to a photo shoot ever in your life Oh
otherwise you'll be kidnapped what you
do a ton of photo shoots like with
people I know and I talked to them first
like cuz I'm cuz I get DM and they're
like their profiles private they got 200
followers and they're like we should
totally shoot I could bring you out here
or we could meet somewhere and I'm like
no like I just rather work with people I
know my friends have worked with because
you just never know like hey why would
you meet in a private setting or even
let them book you hotel like I feel like
can we one FaceTime can we like meet at
a Starbucks or something because people
are [ __ ] crazy
t-tomorrow taught me that the guy
pulling has the Italian photographer
little creepy man and then this is
apparently where she was kept for six
days is this the police investigation
photo since then yeah I don't buy it I
feel bad I don't know
I mean if it's true I'm glad she got off
what's fishy about it everything we
pointed out already
all of us are there these guys that are
terrorizing women and selling them for
sex for money and then they all of a
sudden have morals because she has a kid
like they don't because I feel like your
father's a criminal I would utilize the
kid even more and kidnapped the kid yeah
tell that company I have not only the
mom and the kid in figure out how to
wrap some family members like I can't
picture myself like if I'm already I
already put myself in that mindset right
if I'm already down to she's a product I
don't give a [ __ ] if she's a kid or
grandma or a parent and you spent money
alright your name is stapled to it like
so much like at that point whether you
do have those morals or not you need it
just flow with it because otherwise
you're [ __ ] now and you're gonna go to
jail like you did and that's part of the
branding like if if in our conference
room is said Black Death a group of guys
look we are Black Death group we don't
care about kids care about sons that's
what we do is that your Russian accent
are our rule number one company values
[ __ ] family
I remind everybody number two everybody
dies everybody including you and me we
are including us black death clue we're
in this group do you see but excluding
children and mothers these guys know
they're doing good branding for them yes
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check out up here
[Music]